oui la direction well as why are well as
voyages voilà voyez un verre we are
french people
do you want to be back
emmanuel macron s'est rendu cet après
midi à la teste de buch et ce soir il
est à langon auprès de toutes les
personnes qui depuis des jours en font
face aux incendies le président de la
république a remercié nos héros les
pompiers il affirme qu'il faut acheter
plus d'avions pour lutter contre les
feux qui pourraient se multiplier sous
l'effet du dérèglement climatique
mais que non alors il va pas chez oui
voilà tous deux buteurs y aurait pu
faire les deux barry donc c'est pas
grave parce que la tête jet du but
hausse et c'est beaucoup plus comment
dirais-je commercial que l'on me rassure
je pense certains commercial sévère mais
un nouveau verre pas le verre de la a6
moi j'ai jamais ça maintenant dans ce
magnifique s'attacher à la traiter
soleil
c'est à dire que si vous voulez je pense
qu'ils ont pu voter monsieur macron de
l'autre côté de chez nous
tout de suite non c'est plus touristique
de l'île on dit faut pas tirer sur
l'ambulance maintenant tout le monde
doit faire corps enfin cette situation
contrat
[Musique]
hélas ce qui était beau sais tu vas
encore quelques pas de danse et là il y
avait une timidité et la lascivité
disparaît là on voit des souvenirs
entre temps
c'est complètement
la nuit on a vu ce qui s'est passé
il a réuni les maires de france il s'est
pas passé grand chose après tout
simplement tous des casseroles contre
mâcon quoi qu'il arrive
ça c'est pour vous à la maison 30000
euros à gagner ça n'est pas rien avec
cette question quels instruments de
musique est associé à l'écossé à
l'irlande un nom marie hélène c'est pour
les gens à la mi-temps on l'aura on a
une question réservé pour les
téléspectateurs avant 40 ans l'alcool
est mauvais pour la santé quels que
soient les quantités c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est une étude mondiale très
sérieuse publiée dans la revue
scientifique the lands est selon les
chercheurs de l'étude financée par la
fondation bill et melinda gates les
moins de 40 ans ne devrait tout
simplement jamais boire d'alcool ce
serait dangereux pour le corps dès qu'on
dépasse tenez vous bien plus de deux
cuillérées à café de vin ou 2 cuillerées
à café et demi de bière il ya un four
c'est un génie avec ça pour maintenant
les pied gauche pied droit tu penses ou
d'être
pour les voilà un peu plus d'un an il a
mis dehors c'est la troisième étape on
est à un moment où c'est compliqué de se
faire des cadeaux les uns les autres
attention attention jetons qui à droite
presse conclut à droite bon sang mais si
t'as pas le droit de mettre un pied
dehors alice est bien la plus d'habitude
pour une personne qui à 40 ans ou plus
sans bonne santé consommé de l'alcool
pour y permettre de lutter contre
l'apparition de maladies
cardiovasculaires ou encore de diabète
alors attention je vous à venir ce n'est
pas une raison pour vider sa bouteille
de vin pensant que ça va vous faire du
bien c'est parce que j'ai dit la
consommation d'alcool de rester basse
toujours avec modération moins de deux
verres de vin ou de bière par jour en
moyenne il ya des gens ça ne dérange pas
de marché sur les autres
plantes restent bloqués en fait on pas
c'est toi accepter que des personnes
peuvent être comme ça nous on n'est pas
comme ça et on va montrer justement qu
humainement on va sortir encore plus
forts on n'a pas été sympa mais bon à la
guerre comme à la guerre au royaume uni
boris johnson fait aujourd'hui ses
adieux en tant que premier ministre
alors qu'il était dans la tourmente
depuis plusieurs mois en attendant la
désignation de son successeur il a pris
une dernière fois la parole à
westminster et on peut dire que boris
johnson a fait le show écouter
l'apprenti vide du lavoir webnet les
presse il faut l'attraper cette capsule
et aux résultats
voilà ça va ouais bof et s'il allait